CONGRESSMAN IS NOT AVAILABLE SO
WE WILL HAVE YOU GUYS STAY HERE.
TODAY’S NEWS SURROUNDING
LIEUTENANT GENERAL FLYNN HAS
ABSOLUTE NOTHING TO DO WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, AS GREG JUST
SAID, BUT THAT DIDN’T STOP THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA ECHO CHAMBER
FROM ONCE AGAIN PREDICTING THE
DOWNFALL OF THE ADMINISTRATION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE THING THAT STRUCK ME
COMING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
PODIUM SAYS THAT THIS HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE PRESIDENT
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE PRESIDEN
PRESIDENT.
>> HOW DOES THIS EVEN COME OUT
OF THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY ’S MOUTH?
>> GENERAL FLYNN HAD A LOT OF
INCRIMINATING EVIDENCE.
>> THEY’VE ALWAYS TREATED HIM
WITH KID GLOVES AS OPPOSED TO
OTHERS IN THIS MELODRAMA.
AND WE DON’T KNOW WHY MIKE FLYNN
LIED, WE DON’T KNOW WHY ANYONE
INCLUDING PRESIDENT TRUMP
DIRECTED HIM TO DO IT AND IF
TRUMP DID PLAY A ROLE IN THIS,
IS THAT WHY THE PRESIDENT IS
TREATING MIKE FLYNN WITH KID
GLOVES?
>> THE JUDGE FINDS THIS BEHAVIOR
TREASONOUS.
NOT JUST FLYNN BUT ALL THE
PEOPLE FLYNN COORDINATED WITH IN
CREATING THESE LIES.
IT’S A BAD DAY FOR THE NARRATIVE
THAT THIS IS JUST A WITCH HUNT
AND THERE IS NOTHING SERIOUS
THEY ARE.
>> Judge Jeanine: JOINING US
NOW IS THE AUTHOR OF "WHY WE
FIGHT."
SEBASTIAN GORKA.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT SEEMS TO
CONTINUOUSLY COME BACK AT US IS,
JAMES COMEY LYING OR BEING
INCONSISTENT IN TERMS OF HIS OWN
ANSWERS REGARDING THE SAME THING
ANSWERS REGARDING THE SAME THIN
THING.
FOR EXAMPLE, THERE HAD TO BE A
COINCIDENCE THAT AFTER THE
TARMAC MEETING BETWEEN
BILL CLINTON AND LORETTA LYNCH,
THERE HAD TO BE A MEETING
BETWEEN THE CHIEF JUSTICE AND
THE FBI BUT NOTHING WAS EVER
MENTIONED ABOUT THIS.
>> NOT ONLY THAT BUT WE KNOW
THAT JAMES COMEY AFTER HIS
CLASSIFIED MEETING, IS BRIEFING
WITH PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP, HE
GETS INTO AN FBI VEHICLE AND ON
AN FBI LAPTOP, WRITES UP A MEMO
THAT IS BY NATURE CLASSIFIED,
DUE TO A SUMMARY MEETING OF THE
PRESIDENT IN WHICH HE GIVES TO
HIS LAW PROFESSOR FRIEND AS A
LEAK TO THE MEDIA.
WITH REGARDS TO WHAT HAPPENED
TODAY, IT’S VERY, VERY CLEAR.
I WAS ON THE TRANSITION TEAM
WITH GENERAL FLYNN AND I WORK IN
THE WHITE HOUSE WITH GENERAL
FLYNN.
THE CALL TO THE RUSSIAN
AMBASSADOR WAS ACTUALLY LEGAL.
THE CONTENTS OF THE CONVERSATION
WERE LIKEWISE UTTERLY LEGAL,
REQUESTING POTENTIALLY THE
RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR’S SUPPORT IN
A VOTE AT THE U.N. TO PREVENT
ISRAEL FROM BEING BOYCOTTED.
HOW IS THAT ILLEGAL?
BUT THE FBI HAD THE FULL
TRANSCRIPT OF THE DISCUSSION, SO
WHY DID JIM COMEY SEND THOSE
AGENTS TO THE WHITE HOUSE IN
FULL FLAGRANT DENIAL OF THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL PROCEDURE?
IT WAS A CLASSIC ENTRAPMENT
PLOY.
>> Judge Jeanine: NOT LEGAL
ENTRAPMENT IN THE SENSE THAT WE
PROSECUTORS UNDERSTAND IT, BUT
WHAT IT WAS, WAS A SET UP.
LET’S BRING INTO THE
CONVERSATION REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN DARRELL ISAIAH.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND THOSE
THE ISSUE THAT WE JUST HEARD, BY
ON THE LEFT, THEY HAVE FLYNN
GUILTY OF TREASON.
FLYNN SHOULD BE IN JAIL.
SOMETIMES I WONDER IF WE ARE
WATCHING THE SAME NEWS.
IN FACT, THE PROSECUTOR IS EVEN
SAID THAT IS NOT APPROPRIATE
TREASON IN THE SITUATION.
AND YET, THE OVERREACH IS
NONSTOP.
>> WHAT SEBASTIAN GORKA JUST
SAID IS IMPORTANT FOR YOUR
VIEWERS TO UNDERSTAND, WHICH IS
ANYTHING THAT HE MAY HAVE DONE
FOR WHICH HE MAY HAVE TO PAY A
PRICE, NONE OF IT WAS DONE, IF
YOU WILL, RELATIVE TO THE
INVESTIGATION OF ANY WRONGDOING
BY THE PRESIDENT.
NOTHING WAS DONE THERE.
HE FAILED TO REGISTER AS A
FOREIGN AGENT AND HE LIED TO THE
FBI, AND WHETHER IT IS
ENTRAPMENT OR NOT, REMEMBER THAT
JAMES COMEY HAD ONE INTENTION
CLEARLY, BEFORE DONALD TRUMP WAS
PRESIDENT, AND AFTERWARDS, WHICH
WAS TO GET TO DONALD TRUMP.
YOU COULD SEE IT IN EVERYTHING
HE DID.
HE DIDN’T KEEP FLYNN FROM
BECOMING A NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR, WHICH HE POTENTIALLY
COULD HAVE DONE WITH THE
TRANSCRIPT IF IT WAS VOLATILE.
HE COULD HAVE TOLD THE PRESIDENT
THAT FLYNN WAS MISLEADING OR
LYING TO PEOPLE, WHICH COULD
HAVE AFFECTED HIS BEING FIRED
SOONER AND CERTAINLY IN THE NAME
OF NATIONAL SECURITY WOULD HAVE
BEEN THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
JAMES COMEY FROM DAY ONE HAS
BEEN A CORRUPT COP TRYING TO GET
TO THE PRESIDENT AND IT SHOWS IN
TO THE PRESIDENT AND IT SHOWS INEVERYTHING HE HAS DONE INCLUDING
EVERYTHING HE HAS DONE INCLUDING
WHAT HE FAILED TO DO, WHICH WAS
TO BE HONEST TO BOTH
BARACK OBAMA AND TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT WHAT HE KNEW, WHEN
HE KNEW IT AND WHAT SHOULD BE
DONE IN THE NAME OF NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> Judge Jeanine: SEBASTIAN
GORKA, THE WHOLE CONCEPT, AND
THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
AND, THAT WAS ABSOLUTELY CLEAR
THAT WAS NOT THE CASE.
>> TODAY’S PROCEEDINGS WERE A
FARCE.
FIRST THE FAR ACT, NOBODY HAS
GONE TO JAIL FOR WRITING AN
OP-ED FOR A NATO ALLY, WHICH IS
WHAT GENERAL FLYNN DID.
WE ARE NOT AT WAR WITH TURKEY NO
MATTER HOW MUCH WE DISLIKE AIR
TO ONE.
SECONDLY, THIS LOGAN ACT CHARGE
AGAINST THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR.
IF THE LOGAN ACT WERE ABOUT A
SERIOUS CRIME, AND WHEN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION CAME INTO
POWER.
WHERE IS JOHN KERRY’S ARREST,
WHY ISN’T HE BEING WOKEN UP AT
2:00 A.M. AND PUT IN MANACLES
AND SHACKLES.
IT’S ABSOLUTE ABSURDITY.
>> IT’S FEAR, AND AS WE LISTEN
TO THE FACTS AND WE ARE GETTING
THE FACTS OUT HERE, THE FEAR IS
THAT NONE OF THE ILLEGALITY, THE
UNETHICAL BEHAVIOR ON THE PART
OF THE PEOPLE ON    ON THE LEFT,
OF THE PEOPLE ON    ON THE LEFTA
OF THE PEOPLE ON    ON THE LEFTE
THEY EVER GOING TO BE MADE
ACCOUNTABLE?
THEY SKATED THERE WERE DURING
OBAMA’S EIGHT YEARS AND THEY ARE
SKATING THROUGH THE FIRST TWO
YEARS BECAUSE OF GOOD OLD JEFF
SESSIONS.
AND HOPE SPRINGS ETERNAL AS IT
RELATES TO THIS NEW GUY, BUT
WHAT DO YOU THINK WILL HAPPEN?
>> I THINK THE INSURANCE POLICY
THAT LISA PAGE AND PETER STRZOK
TALKED ABOUT HAS BEEN WORKING
FOR TWO YEARS.
FOR TWO YEARS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN DISTRACTED FROM
THE REAL ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THIS
PRESIDENT, AND HE HAS BEEN
FORCED TO BOTH DO THE WORK OF
THE PRESIDENT AND TO DEAL WITH
THESE ENDLESS ASSAULTS.
LET’S FACE IT.
TWO YEARS AGO, JAMES COMEY DID
NOT TELL THE PRESIDENT THINKS HE
SHOULD HAVE TOLD HIM BECAUSE HE
WAS TRYING TO INDICT THE
PRESIDENT.
IT’S NOW BEEN TWO YEARS LATER
AND HE STILL DOESN’T HAVE A CASE
EVEN WITH THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
OR ESSENTIALLY HIS BODY,
MUELLER.
>> IT IS HIS BODY, MUELLER,
INDEED.
THIS GUY WAS HIS GUARDIAN ANGEL
DURING THOSE FAMOUS JOHN
ASHCROFT HOSPITAL MOMENTS THAT
HE REMEMBERS VIVIDLY BUT CAN’T
REMEMBER 245 TIMES, ANYTHING
THAT’S HAPPENED IN THE LAST FEW
MONTHS WHEN HE APPEARS BEFORE
CONGRESS.
>> THAT’S HIS EXAMPLE OF
LEADERSHIP AND BEING LOYAL TO
THE TRUTH.
THE FACT IS, ROBERT MUELLER IS
SUCH A CONFLICT OF INTEREST FROM
DAY ONE OF BECOMING SPECIAL
COUNSEL, WHY ROD ROSENSTEIN.
WE HAVE TO RECALL THIS.
ROD ROSENSTEIN MADE HIM SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO INVESTIGATE THE
PRESIDENT THE DAY AFTER ROD
ROSENSTEIN ESCORTED HIM TO THE
WHITE HOUSE TO INTERVIEW FOR THE
JOB LEFT FBI DIRECTOR AGAIN.
ROBERT MUELLER CRASHED AND
BURNED IN THAT INTERVIEW.
THE PRESIDENT SAID IT, NO, I
NEED NEW BLOOD, YOU WILL NOT BE
THE NEW DIRECTOR.
LESS THAN 24 HOURS LATER, ROD
ROSENSTEIN MAKES HIM THE SPECIAL